how did a canine companion keep stevo
sober where did the part-time stuntman
and full-time troublemaker get his
unmistakable voice and did he really go
to clown college this is the untold
truth of stevo
for stevo the path to jackass stardom
began long before the show itself he
told forbes that he first began
experimenting with videotaping when his
dad won a camera from a golf tournament
while the comedian was still a teenager
stevo took the camera from his dad's
closet and used it to film skateboard
tricks with his friends discovering that
he had a real knack and passion for
filming in the process it wasn't until
after stevo went to college at the
university of miami that he got the idea
to film more elaborate stunts he told
forbes i spent more time partying and
jumping off the diving boards at the
pool than going to class which was why i
got dumped by my girlfriend in the midst
of park break stevo turned back to
filming and started to videotape himself
performing dangerous stunts the
reactions he got from people who watched
his tapes convinced him to drop out of
school and become a performer
stevo's stint at the university of miami
wasn't the end of his education he later
attended the ringling brothers and
barnum and bailey clown college with 32
other classmates stevo told graham
bensinger that he got the opportunity to
work alongside another group of clowns
on a cruise ship the job only lasted a
season though because quote there was a
clown mutiny the other clowns didn't get
along with stevo and they all threatened
to leave if he returned for another
season so the management fired him
luckily the jump also gave stevo the
inspiration for a major stunt standing
on stilts stevo would light his clown
suit on fire then have a unicycler ride
through his legs while a skateboarder
jumped over his head and threw a
fireball that he spit out of his mouth
for the finale he'd chug a beer and tip
over stevo called jeff tremaine to pitch
the idea and they filmed the stunt as a
pilot for mtv the station refused to air
the stunt but liked the idea and stevo
enough to create jackass
who knew that being an over-the-top
stuntman could land you in jail stevo
found out the hard way in july 2002 when
a performance at a nightclub in
louisiana nearly landed him behind bars
with a felony two of the stunts in
stevo's performance came back to bite
him first he received a principle to
second-degree battery charge for
presiding over a stunt that ended in a
club bouncer knocking a college student
unconscious then he got a felony
obscenity charge for stapling his
scrotum to his thigh after much
negotiation first assistant district
attorney mark rhodes said that the
prosecution agreed that stevo hadn't
been an active participant in the
battery and that his scrotum stapling
was quote more than likely protected
under free speech when conducted in
front of paying adult patrons stevo
avoided charges and a trial by agreeing
to be on a probation for one year donate
five thousand dollars to a local shelter
for battered women and children and to
never perform in terrebonne again
the louisiana incident wasn't the last
time one of stevo's stunts led him into
legal troubles in fact he was arrested
again in sweden just a few months later
this time he swallowed a condom full of
marijuana and snuck it through customs
as a stunt for the don't try this at
home show he and his fellow jackass
members were performing in stockholm
stevo's fans know him as a stuntman and
some even know him as a stand-up
comedian but not many people are aware
of stevo the rapper back in 2011 he
recorded and released the album the
dumbest
hip-hop to not much fanfare at all the
cd included a bonus dvd of more stevo
content and a poster of the album cover
that read never before has a rapper been
so
dumb with tracks like crack cocaine and
popping off it's no surprise that
stevo's album didn't break the charts
but that was likely never his goal to
begin with even stevo's fans more or
less forgot the album entirely the
moment it was released stevo never
released a follow-up album and it
doesn't seem likely that he ever will
but fans can always go back and enjoy
one of the stranger moments in the
stuntman's career for themselves
stevo went through a massive lifestyle
change in the late 2000s after years of
performing wild stunts partially fueled
by drugs and alcohol he decided to get
sober and he's maintained that sobriety
since 2008. when talking about it stevo
makes what was likely a lengthy and
difficult decision seemed totally simple
he told men's health here's what got me
motivated to change i hit a wall i
really reached a point where thank god
my life got so bad that i had to
surrender to the process of recovery the
process has entirely transformed his
life and it's left him with plenty of
energy for more stunts of course no one
goes through recovery alone and stevo
credits his rescue dogs walter and
bernie with keeping him going he adopted
his first dog when he first embarked on
the recovery journey in 2008 and he said
it's been good for him to quote have a
priority that's not myself since then
stevo's dogs have become his closest
friends they've helped to deepen his
connection with animals in general and
that's become a major part of his life
stevo has been an outspoken animal
rights activist for years and sometimes
he combines his passion for ridiculous
stunts with his love of animals to
powerful results in 2014 stevo and five
of his friends changed a sea world drive
sign just outside of san diego to say
sea world sucks doing that was wrong i
don't want to be right
that got people talking not as much as
stevo might have wanted so the following
year he upped the ante stevo knows how
to get attention and climbing a 100 foot
crane certainly did the trick the
machine hovered above sunset boulevard
which gave the performer the perfect
spot to speak to the world through a
giant shamu balloon with just two words
on it sea world sucks at the top of the
crane stevo set off a series of
fireworks before making his way back to
the ground where he was promptly
arrested from the streets below law
enforcement couldn't tell whether the
man on the crane was suicidal so they
deployed a whole team to air on the side
of caution a helicopter five ambulances
and close to 100 firefighters
prosecutors charged stevo with five
misdemeanors that could have landed him
in jail for more than four years he
reached a plea deal for 30 days in jail
three years probation and a 14 000
reimbursement to the city of los angeles
in the end stevo reported for his
sentence at twin towers correctional
facility but he was released after
serving less than eight hours
in addition to fighting for animal
rights with attention-grabbing public
displays stevo also altered his own
lifestyle to align with his values he
told us weekly that he became a vegan
shortly after he started his recovery
and the decision impacted way more than
his diet he said i think it's benefited
every area of my life
since that interview stevo hasn't gone
back to his meat-eating ways but these
days he says that he's not vegan he's
technically a pescetarian because he'll
eat fish and eggs from time to time
that's not his biggest slip-up though he
told men's health i've been letting a
lot of dairy slide too even admitting
that i have a problem with that despite
having been a vegan himself stevo has
also been critical of vegans in the past
he wrote on instagram to all the
combative annoying vegans who are
choosing to attack me for not forcing
veganism on my cats and for not being a
strict militant vegan myself maybe stop
working so hard to pit people who are on
your team against you the post garnered
plenty of backlash from some vegan
commenters but stevo has never been one
to care about haters
every jackass fan is familiar with
stevo's voice there's just nothing quite
like it he has the gravelly rumble of a
cigarette smoking blues singer but he
sounded like that for over 20 years i
always thought that my world record for
barfing the most on television might
have something to do with it over the
years he's also speculated that his
unique tone could have come from
swallowing glass or consuming copious
amounts of nitrous oxide in his younger
years eventually stevo decided to
consult with the doctor to find out the
root of his raspy voice and the answer
wasn't at all what he expected it turns
out stevo sounds that way because he
uses his throat muscles rather than his
vocal cords to talk to prevent his
condition from getting worse stevo
started working on using his vocal cords
with a voice coach but he wasn't
entirely sold on changing his signature
sound but i don't even know if i want my
voice to change i kind of like getting
recognized over the phone and my girl
darn sure doesn't want it any different
no i love your voice
chances are even if stevo learns how to
talk the right way he'll continue to
sound like he always has
after making his name as a stuntman
stevo decided to stretch his abilities
and try out a new career path he began
working as a stand-up comedian in 2011
and he spent the past decade touring
various shows and approaching stand-up
with the same determination he once
aimed at his stuntman ambitions stevo
has completed two comedy specials gnarly
which was the first special he took on
tour and the bucket list which she began
touring just as the coronavirus pandemic
shuttered venues across the country his
stand-up acts have always incorporated
some of his stuntman roots but the
bucket list takes things to a whole new
level notably he incorporates footage of
brand new stunts and stories into his
act creating a multimedia experience for
the audience despite all the work that
stevo has put into a stand-up axe he's
had a difficult time getting them out to
anyone who isn't in his live audience he
would gladly give the axe to a streaming
platform like netflix but so far there
hasn't been any interest in his work he
spoke to graham bensinger in 2019
regarding the possibility of his getting
a comedy special on netflix that they
only want to give them to the most
prestigious
pure
you know lifelong stand-up comedians
of which they do not consider me to be
one in the same interview with graham
bensinger stevo explained that he and
his fiancee lux wright met on a job that
never ended up seeing the light of day
even though the project ended up being a
failure it gave stevo the opportunity to
meet the love of his life the two of
them don't plan on ever having kids but
they still have big plans for their
future opening an animal sanctuary where
they'll eventually be able to live when
they retire you don't have to know us
very well to know that we love animals
stevo told bensinger we want to have it
in southern california so we can drive
to it
ideally it would also operate as a bed
and breakfast that would give people the
opportunity to stay longer and develop
deeper relationships with the animals
they're visiting stevo said he hopes it
gives people pause the next time they go
to eat an animal for dinner he went on
to explain in the long term the
sanctuary would also become a daycare
for children with special needs stevo's
nephew has down syndrome and autism and
he has witnessed the stress his sister
has put under while trying to manage her
career and take care of her children he
wants to be able to give back to parents
with similar struggles and his fiancee
is more than happy to create that legacy
with him check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite celebrities
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]